[Music]
all right
no you are not lying I will save you
lunch
and the rest of you play double time
[Music]
Spidey splinter
[Applause]
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] boots
Puss and Boots you are down to your last
life
you need to retire
[Music]
oh brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
well I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero
a legend right this is a person party
that's your party so this is where
dignity Goes To Die the year start
coming and they don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either you're
funny what's your what's your story my
story
what are we looking at cats have nine
lives watch watch watch
I think you should be having too high no
I am on my last laugh oh no
but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
[Music]
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
you will find your reward does not come
easily what's in Boots Goldie there's
all right
[Music]
spare I am nothing when you only have
one life that's what makes it special go
get him tiger hey take it easy
this is gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]